[Music]
with the TV you can make a continuing
story and you can over a long period of
time people can get to know characters
and and and fall into another world and
have so many great experiences in it and
it reaches so many people at unites you
know people it's a so beautiful she's
dead
wrapped in plastic it's a story about
you know a young woman gets killed in
the town and the FBI agent comes in and
so on and so forth but what it becomes
as a character study of all these
different people in this town and how
idiosyncratic people are Diana's fort
enemy happened at the scene of the crime
here's something we haven't seen before
I think what makes it more unique is the
way it's shot and the the way the small
town is presented especially in the
pilot
it's a Northwest which hasn't been seen
a lot when you see the pilot it really
has a whole feeling about it it really
seems like a little town of a community
people know each other and whispering
behind corners and wanting to find out
the gospel about that one I think she
knows about us
it's a place that you look at and you
think you'd love to live in you know the
people are very charming um a little
quirky and then the more time you spend
looking at the town or being in the town
and being around the people you see that
everything isn't what it looks like the
characters are so so intriguing so
bizarre do such strange things
unexpected things in situations that are
very odd I think it's just it's just the
nature of the show it's just the unknown
the unknown factor
the lady with the log we're cold Mowgli
the cult figure thing it's not really
anything I did I just did this role and
it captured people's imaginations so I'm
kind of they're giving something that
I'm not really clear what it is you know
so I mean it's an interesting phenomenon
it kind of cracks me up how much people
want an answer to the who killed Laura
Palmer thing because that murder was
just kind of the ball that got
everything rolling you know and it was
what helped uncover all of these other
wonderful relationships and secrets and
all these other characters you know how
they all relate and what's going on with
them keep hearing that question over and
over who killed you Quinn click you know
there's so much other stuff going on who
could figure than in Spain and Italy and
in England and Japan and many many other
countries that something like this that
seems so sort of homespun could be
understood and appreciated so so much
and intensely it's there's no figuring
it all I keep saying is it's the mystery
of the woods and it's it's the same kind
of thing that a fairy tale you know gets
going on it's a once you start walking
in the woods your imagination starts
going and that there's you know some of
this in the world of twin land of twin
peaks well you know what if they ask us
to come back I'm sure it'd be a real
pleasure to see our friends again
[Music]